[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos es un hecho china está de moda la
influencia del régimen de pekín en el
mundo nunca ha sido tan grande como lo
es ahora ni tampoco la fama y la
presencia de china en los medios de
comunicación de todo el planeta y sabéis
el responsable de todo esto es este
hombre
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sitting pink se ha convertido en el
presidente de china quien más poder ha
acumulado desde la caída de mouse de
donde llegó al poder en el año 2013 con
dos grandes promesas ampliar el poder y
la influencia de china en el mundo por
un lado y consolidar el poder político
del partido comunista por el otro de
esta forma el presidente chino quiere
terminar con esa idea tan extendida de
que el desarrollo económico va seguido
siempre de transiciones políticas y
procesos democráticos
pero amigos para conseguir sus metas y
de paso consolidar su poder si jinping
tiene antes que sacarse dos grandes
piedras del zapato dos piedras que
perciben como toda una amenaza la
cohesión y la identidad nacional de
china estoy hablando de taiwán y hong
kong
[Música]
y precisamente de este último
protagonista de hong kong es de quién
vamos a hablaros en este vídeo
[Música]
hong kong está viviendo las que ya son
las mayores protestas civiles desde el
fin de la colonización británica y ya va
en camino de convertirse también en las
más largas
el detonante tiene el nombre y apellido
la ley de extradición veréis propuesta
por la jefa ejecutiva de hong kong
carril amp siguiendo los deseos de pekín
esta ley permitiría extraditar a los
ciudadanos hongkoneses para ser juzgados
y en su caso encarcelados en la china
continental es decir esta propuesta de
ley venía a reconocer la validez de los
tribunales controlados por el partido
comunista chino y aunque finalmente tras
la presión de los manifestantes la
propuesta de ley haya sido retirada es
una clara muestra de cómo empiezan a
funcionar las cosas en hong kong
pero amigos porque ha sido esta
propuesta en concreto la que ha hecho
reventar la paciencia de la sociedad con
con esa trascendencia tiene más allá de
la propia ley estamos acaso asistiendo a
un punto de inflexión histórico en la
relación entre la excolonia y china-
atentos
[Música]
ley de extradición la gota que colma el
vaso así es amigos lo de la ley de
extradición no es ni más ni menos que la
gota que ha colmado el vaso porque no no
penséis que todo esto empezó aquí ni
muchísimo menos las injerencias de pekín
en la política de hong kong y la
proposición por parte de las propias
autoridades con con esas de leyes pro
china que en realidad se emanan del
propio régimen continental del propio
régimen chino han sido algo
prácticamente constante desde la
transferencia a china en 1997 queréis
algún ejemplo fijaos
en el año 2003 tan solo seis años
después del traspaso a china el
ejecutivo hongkonés propuso la llamada
ley de seguridad nacional una ley que
perseguía prohibir y castigar cualquier
movimiento independentista ekin buscaba
y digo buscaba porque la ley se canceló
blindar su soberanía sobre el territorio
y pisotear a la oposición sin embargo no
contaba con un pequeño estudio china se
topó con la oposición feroz de la
ciudadanía hong kong esa que se lanzó a
las calles dando lugar a las mayores
protestas de la historia en hong kong
hasta ahora
si hasta ahora porque las protestas de
2019 ya han superado con creces a las de
2003 y la verdad es que sobran motivos
[Música]
fijaos imagínate que vives en un
territorio con un sistema económico
independiente una justicia garantista y
una sociedad con un montón de libertades
como por supuesto el acceso a la
internet y a las redes sociales y de
repente un régimen dictatorial con el
que no te sientes nada pero que nada
identificado un régimen donde no existe
ninguno de estos derechos y libertades y
donde la justicia está controlada por el
partido único pretende imponer una ley
que permita que tú mismo pueda ser
extraditado para ser juzgado bajo ese
régimen y sus condiciones que harías
entonces
así que el descontento y la rabia
aparece más que justificado no creéis al
fin y al cabo la ley de extradición
aunque aparentemente dejará fuera las
acusaciones políticas suponía de facto
el fin del modelo de autonomía de hong
kong porque claro vamos a ver no me
digáis que os cuesta imaginaros a un
tribunal chino pidiendo la extradición
de un disidente un opositor político de
hong kong por cualquier otro motivo
a que no
[Música]
e
la ley de extradición es la sentencia de
muerte para hong kong dice el librero
exiliado lahm wing que pekín usará esta
ley para controlar hong kong
completamente la libertad de expresión
se perderá en el pasado el régimen
secuestró a sus críticos como yo
ilegalmente con esta ley ellos abdú
tiran a sus críticos legalmente pues
bien el caso es que el descontento es
tan grande que según un reciente estudio
del programa de opinión pública de la
universidad de hong kong nunca antes del
rechazo a china había sido tan grande
entre los ciudadanos de este territorio
como lo es ahora
[Música]
e
pero eso no es todo lo peor es la
sensación general que existe de que el
ejecutivo hongkonés responde a los
intereses de china y no a los intereses
de sus propios ciudadanos
[Música]
y eso es un problema en un territorio
donde los ciudadanos no pueden cambiar
las cosas porque lo cierto es que la
democracia no existe en hong kong no hay
sufragio universal y el jefe del
ejecutivo el jefe del gobierno se
propone desde pekín vamos a ver en un
país normal democrático y libre sin
gobernante lo hace mal gobierna en
contra de los intereses del pueblo o se
descubre que favorece a otros intereses
pues la gente le deja de votar a él oa
su partido y oye pueden deshacer lo que
no les gusta
sin embargo está aquí no es una
posibilidad amigos tras el traspaso a
china el sistema político de hong kong
se ha convertido en algo muy pero que
muy parecido a una especie de régimen
corporativista que gobierna para los
intereses de dos poderosas manos la mano
de hierro china por un lado y la mano
del dinero de los grandes empresarios
favorables
por otro especialmente de los grandes
jerarcas del mundo inmobiliario que han
logrado formar todo un oligopolio donde
este territorio donde hong kong no es
más que un mercado cautivo su servicio
[Música]
sorprendido pues no deberías de hecho el
sistema político hong kong alimenta y
mucho este modelo
[Música]
en hong kong el jefe del ejecutivo líder
del gobierno es elegido mediante
sufragio censitario por los miembros del
comité de elección que cuenta con unas
1200 personas pero y quién elige a estos
1200 representantes pues para ser
sinceros es más fácil empezar contando
con quienes no votan los ciudadanos
hablamos de un sistema muy complicado en
el que participan organizaciones
sectoriales líderes religiosos líderes
empresariales sindicatos e incluso
empresas todo orquestado para refrendar
el poder de china
fijaos por ejemplo lo que ocurre con el
sector de la agricultura que
tradicionalmente ha sido afín a pekín
pues bien a pesar de suponer tan sólo el
0 1 por ciento de la economía de este
territorio los agricultores tienen más
peso en el comité de elección que
sectores mucho muchísimo más importantes
como por ejemplo el sector financiero
muy democrático como veis no parece
verdad pues así con todo
[Música]
de hecho es la falta de democracia el
verdadero motivo de las protestas
actuales y también de muchas de las
protestas pasadas y es que veréis a
pesar de no existir técnicamente la
democracia hong kong es y ha sido
durante décadas un epicentro regional
muy importante de activismo político y
de la disidencia contra pekín
[Música]
y la ley de extradición pues tenía como
consecuencia de facto terminar con todas
esas libertades si lo pensáis esto es lo
más dramático del caso en hong kong no
es que estemos ya ante una dictadura
queriendo salirse con la suya sino que
estamos presenciando como personas
acostumbradas a vivir en libertad ven
día a día como están perdiendo toda esa
libertad y esto es lo que explica lo que
viene a continuación atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la triple libertad cuesta abajo y sin
frenos así es amigos en hong kong las
tres libertades están en caída libre y
sin frenos la libertad económica la
libertad individual y la libertad
política las tres han empeorado desde
que china se hizo cargo del territorio
en 1997
[Música]
y eso eso es algo que tiene
consecuencias a todos los niveles
especialmente en un lugar que ha sido
tradicionalmente conocido por su
escrupuloso respeto a la seguridad
jurídica y por la estabilidad
institucional porque eso es lo que
explica el éxito de hong kong y que por
ejemplo unas 1500 empresas
multinacionales tengan su sede asiática
en este territorio sin embargo amigos
ahora todo esto puede terminar mal no
solo en el terreno político sino también
en el terreno económico
veréis me explicó las continuas
injerencias de china se están
traduciendo en muchos casos en graves
gravísimas violaciones de la seguridad
jurídica de las empresas para que os
hagáis una idea en el terreno económico
china ha incrementado sus chantajes a
empresas privadas para que mantengan una
postura crítica con cualquier movimiento
opositor a pekín ya sabéis si no quieren
tener problemas para permanecer en el
gran mercado chino
[Música]
es lo que ha ocurrido por ejemplo con la
aerolínea hongkonesa cathay pacific que
ha sufrido las consecuencias de no ser
criticada durante las protestas en
contra de la ley de extradición de no
ser crítica y de no controlar
suficientemente las expresiones
políticas de sus propios trabajadores
cathay pacific sustituye a su director
ejecutivo por el aumento de las
presiones de china el personal de cathay
pacific habla de clima del miedo los
empleados de cathay pacific dicen que
temen perder sus trabajos y expresan
apoyo a los manifestantes por democracia
en hong kong
algunos están considerando llevar
móviles de señuelo en caso de que sus
teléfonos sean chequeados al llegar a la
china continental pero no no penséis que
esto se acaba aquí
amigos la represión en el terreno
empresarial a los sectores productivos
está llegando incluso a casos de boicots
organizados por el propio gobierno chino
a través de redes sociales y no se salva
a nadie ni siquiera el té de burbujas
[Música]
la batalla del té de burbujas las marcas
taiwanesas se enfrentan al boicot en la
china continental por sus gestos sobre
hong kong y lo peor es que no estamos
hablando de pequeños casos aislados en
absoluto
xi jinping sabe que dirige un país con
uno de los mercados más deseados para
toda empresa que se precie una población
abrumadoramente enorme una clase media
cada vez mayor y un poder de consumo a
niveles ya exorbitantes están en china
es estar cerca del éxito y si sabe que
esta es una de sus grandes bazas para
presionar políticamente utilizando el
comercio y el sector empresarial
y eso es algo que evidentemente no
tranquiliza a ninguna compañía un
traspiés y por no hablar de cómo día
antes vas a controlar a tus empleados
cómo vas a alentar su libertad de
expresión cómo vas a atraer talento con
semejantes condiciones en fin se empieza
con el té de burbujas y se acaba con
cualquier empresa que no haga lo que
china de plazca y claro esto no sólo es
algo reprobable sino también
irresponsable
[Música]
esta actitud de china junto a la
protección a los oligarcas y el
sometimiento del gobierno local que
están terminando con la prosperidad de
hong kong los hongkoneses sienten que
están perdiendo no sólo sus libertades
políticas sino que también está en
riesgo su propio bienestar económico
porque amigos y hong kong pierde su
independencia a su seguridad jurídica y
su neutralidad que vientres le queda
[Música]
amigos tal vez lo peor de todo es que
hong kong puede que simple y llanamente
ya haya dejado de ser hong kong seguro
que ahora entendéis mejor el porqué de
las protestas y por qué están durando
tanto los ciudadanos de hong kong
sienten que están ante una de sus
últimas posibilidades de resistir que es
ahora o nunca pero si queréis saber por
qué a siguiente le interesa tanto todo
este tema y porque a pesar de todo si no
necesita este pequeño territorio está
muy pero que muy atentos porque se
avecinan más vídeos sobre hong kong en
los que se explicará esta y muchas más
cosas por supuesto para ello tenéis que
suscribiros abisal político y a ser
posible darle a la campanita pero ahora
ahora es turno para ti crees que la
presión del pueblo de hong kong logrará
que se respeten las libertades políticas
e individuales del territorio o por
contra estamos presenciando el principio
del fin de loncón que todos conocemos
amigos dejadme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios aquí abajo y también en esta
encuesta y por supuesto ya sabéis si
este vídeo se resultó interesante no
olvidéis darle a like un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]